PHOTOGRAPHERS:
(SHOUTING) Mira! Mira! Mira!
I'm so sick of being
the superhero.
But blockbusters just
let you make movies you love.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
MIRA: I'll be Irma Vep.
This is the part
she's been dying to play.
I told her not to get involved
with those people.
What else can I do?
How's it been going?
You happy?
Mira, I'm never happy.
Who would have thought that you
would end up working with him?
(PAINED GROAN)
René's process can be confusing.
(SPEAKING IN FRENCH)
(GRUNTING)
♪ (MUSIC INTENSIFIES) ♪
You're a stranger
in a strange town.
You play tough,
but you're so candid.
I'm young,
I'm a movie star.
I like when they look at you.
MIRA: What matters
is staying sane.
♪ (MUSIC SWELLS) ♪